in these very dark times when they were
no longer being @midnight and Kid Rock
could soon be making laws and malt
liquor dukey's on the Senate floor giant
icebergs are breaking free from their
ancient mores and hauling ass to Miami
and healthcare might soon just be
trumped just throwing pills out of the
window of Air Force One now we're all
besieged by the creeping premonition
that death will beckon sooner than we
thought and that the only sounds left to
echo and our skulls will be unholy
wailing and gnashing of teeth but don't
worry because every cartoon from the 90s
get no reboot yeah
hmm anyway we can all crap ourselves in
a warm nostalgia Parker for a few
minutes because every cartoon we loved
as a kid will sue me back to remind us
of a time when life was like a box of
chocolates on the horizon we got new
installments of ducktales we got your
Animaniacs err Hey Arnold
Rocko's Modern Life the updated did you
do my son rock again that was my first
hearing ever you are you are nothing
anyway please all updated in the Upstate
a titular character will reportedly
listen to dubstep and pound energy
drinks basically everything you do at a
baby shower in New Jersey so comedians
if Cliff classic cartoon characters keep
getting crammed on our modern age holes
what is the plotline of a reboot that
you would like to see Brandon Fat Albert
goes to jail for what he did to those
women all right
hey hey I'm kidding
he-man can't serve in the Armed Forces
because he used to be she rock all right
boys by the power of capital pink skull
Dan Harmon Thundercats but with dogs so
dog cats death love fishing